hubert-félix thiéfaine que vous avez
entendu et qui sera du côté de maurepas
le 8 septembre ce sera lors du festival
coup d'état on en reparlera juste après
la chronique de l'écho la chronique de
l'écossais avec alice comme tous les
jeudis bonsoir l'islande bon sens
wilfried bonsoir à tous alors dans cette
première chronique échos de l'année on
va s'intéresser aux centres commerciaux
qui sont de plus en plus nombreux sur
notre territoire et face à la
concurrence ils doivent se renouveler
constamment hervé deniau bonsoir en soit
vous êtes directeur des centres espace
saint quentin et skywest ici à montigny
le bretonneux alors avant cela on va
faire un point sur les chiffres du
chômage on en parlait en début
d'émission la barre des trois millions
de demandeurs d'emploi a été dépassé fin
juillet dans toute la france les ivy ne
sont pas épargnés puisque 1,2 pour cent
en plus saintes sur un mois de
demandeurs d'emploi soit une hausse de
7,1 pour cent alors les raisons
principales c'est d'une part la
diminution des missions d'intérim et
d'autre part le non renouvellement des
contrats à durée déterminée
les populations les plus touchées sont
les seniors les plus de 50 ans et puis
les jeunes on va écouter cet éclairage
avec dominique degryse qui est directeur
de pôle emploi dans les yvelines
une croissance significative sur laon
sur les seniors
croissance qui est structurelle là
depuis depuis plus d'un an un les
chiffres il n'y a plus de 13% de
croissance sur le nombre d'emploi des
plus de 50 ans qu'on est plus maintenant
dans la réalité de ski de ski et le
fonctionnement des marchés de l'emploi
avec des difficultés importantes
plus importante pour ces populations de
retour à l'emploi et puis on a des
aspects plus conjoncturelle sur les
yvelines on retrouve un niveau même plus
important que ce qui se passait sur sur
d'autres départements ou sur le niveau
ile de france on a eu une augmentation
de la demande d'emploi des jeunes très
significative sur le mois 2 / mois de
juillet on est à + re +3 %
sur les jeunes c'est même 3,4 alors que
la population globale ne croît que de
1,2 on a vraiment un effet un effet
important sur la population jeune deux
raisons à ça c'est que c'est les
premières populations qui se retrouvent
dans l'émission cdd dans les cdd dans
les missions d'intérim les premières
populations qui vont être concernés par
cette croissance des premières entrées
la croissance des jeunes
dans la demande d'emploi son niveau
line sur les douze derniers mois ces
neuf et demi 3 % rien que sur mode
juillet sur l'île de france expliqué 7%
on est sur un département où le recours
à l'intérim est important on est sur un
département le premier département
industriel d'ile-de-france et
l'industrie est un des secteurs qui
ajuste le plus rapidement des chiffres
sur l'automobile ont été sont parus très
récemment à mon annonce des baisses de
ventes significatives donc aussi qui dit
baisse de lundi est justement de la
production
ajustement du recours à l'intérim danser
pour produire pour produire les autos
pour la sous-traitance fin et tous les
emplois actuels induire c'est à ces
dispositifs
on vient aux centres commerciaux avec
vous et hervé deniau une réaction tout
d'abord à cette conjoncture qui n'est
pas bonne est ce que c'est un frein dans
votre activité
et nous en fait on essaie de contrer ce
marasme on a passé un partenariat
national avec pôle emploi hammerson a
passé un partenariat national et on va
organiser un job dating au mois de
octobre au sein du centre commercial du
corps donc en fait ce sont les
différentes enseignes qui donnent leurs
besoins et puis on essaye de trouver des
personnes exactement sur place il